c кадри us the new мирної демонстрації в
сараєво кретин 1990 іншу руку
тисячі боснійців вийшли на вулиці на Петро
їм кумиру арені стадіону підібгала
стріляні нам спіраль насильства
почала розкручуватись українці tagged
вже пил нас важкі на підйом та уколи
шни їх умова адреса давалася а ще на
учиху вона вина
так близько раб там навчалася відстріляні на
ми не знав їх то цигун та свитка стріляв
і малюка чула свистку для нас це важливо
це було porsche вина в Європі з 1945
руку проти розуму і g4 рокки в сараєвому
булава блозі весь вантаж низьких сервер був
прискорений у шакли щастило шини про ти люди
насті нині боснійській столиці вже
повністю видно в лоно за дикою
мільярдів євро міжнародну папери у
team тріщини між з низькими сербами та
хорватами та мусульманську без шістьох у
сочі
дуже в боки центру дні сподіваємося сайт на
цю музу броні інтерв'ю з боснійцям і
який 25 рокер тому прогнув і лише одного
меру одні з них було marinella до манш
edge ви кладочку тоді висловила
як ви і нас спалахнуло буквально
покращення готелі
гараж ти помер і ми трусив і пораду страху
ми не знала що буває так
закінчилася а демонстрація того дня
доброго номерними
ми прийшли з добрим та номерами бути
страху шнур оптовому бути такий мужик
вчаться була пара нині і в бутті і кидали
їх
проект ще місце інтерв'ю відшивається
назвав і над 6 центру olympic арренів
сараєво на тему стадіоні
zarik до початку провини концерт на Петро ім
кумару долина та vuitton ще гурти це
особисті їхні умови путін вину геть і
натиснули новий вид повернуть і проект по
іклана інколи ти нас кільки кришками
mr ще вина мажор оптово прийти туди
добро на і ніхто і не думав нині боснії
усіо над своїм царям і
понад одинадцять тисяч боснійців
закинув і вище в сараєво блогу та кого
тревал а тисячу чотириста двадцять п'ять
днів